you know I think I may just quit social
media what do you think you think I
ought to quit social media I mean it's
Christmas time Merry Christmas you guys
I'm having a blast
and then I look down at my Twitter feed
people say crap on there that they would
never in a million years have the
courage to say standing in front of you
ever it's just I mean some of you have
no real courage you have digital courage
as all it just it's it's amazing and I
just I'm about to the point that I just
got true I never really cared I've got
pretty thick skin but I'm about to the
point I just don't know if I want that
in my brain anymore
I don't know if I won't put that crap in
my brain the people who have no life and
no courage because I you know I'll tell
you that place you can do this this is
you want to know why some species eat
their young
I'll tell you how read the comments
after any article these negative crazy
article on people commenting after any
article anything from a football coach -
it doesn't matter what the article is
about it all devolves into I love Trump
or I hate Trump it all devolves into
devolve as opposed to evolve okay if you
don't know what that means you write in
the comments all the time so it just
goes down the toilet and the you can
tell these people are there's a lot of
really angry people out there and so
yeah I think I'm gonna continue to stay
continue to carry a firearm there's a
lot of angry people out there Wow and
that have no courage to action you know
if you had you remember in the old days
when you didn't know someone was saying
there's nothing about you because you
didn't have facebook or you didn't know
my wife is sitting there looking at
Facebook this morning she is look at so
incensed and Sarah says
what if you hadn't known that your day
would be better if you didn't know that
and all she's doing electronic gossiping
is all she were doing right she was
looking at looking at somebody that's
some thing that they were doing and
keeping up and see people you know when
you post all that stuff you post on
Facebook you in your little mind you
think everyone that sees that thinks
it's good but some of them said and they
go look at that you know it's just it I
wonder what would it be like without
Facebook I can only dream what could be
like with Twitter without Twitter where
people with no courage can say anything
they want to say because I mean you
would no more walk into my Lobby here or
walk up to me on the street in a neutral
setting and have the courage to say to
me some of the things that some of you
say about me or to me it's amazing
amazing and that's true about everybody
by the way people that you know you
don't even have to be in the celebrity
spotlight to have that you just be have
a Facebook page and then someone will
look at your picture and go well in
shape it now a little weight yeah looks
like the Christmas cookies have been
going you know and you were just posting
a picture having a good time how are
your boyfriend I mean come on you know
and somebody's got something to say you
know that sometimes they say it on
Facebook sometimes they just turn around
and say it to somebody else but she man
it is a bunch of jerks out there Wow
scary stuff yeah I think I would prefer
to just only know you're a jerk is if
you actually had the courage to say to
me something that proved you were a jerk
and then I wouldn't have to think about
it I may just do that I mean it's the
new year coming up Twitter is kind of
dying anyway I can't stand Instagram
rachel loves it Chris Brown loves it
they can do it they have they have slits
in their jeans my jeans don't have holes
in them so I can't do Instagram yeah
that's one of the rules it's a federal
law you're not supposed to be on the
Instagram if you don't have slits in
your jeans
so um and I don't really need to do an
instant story about anything I just
can't think of anything that's important
enough for me to do in the insta story
about it so I might just do that I'm
gonna have to think about this it's kind
of spontaneous it launched me into this
sort of half-butt rant that's not really
that good and wandering but I might just
abandon social media
I will pay somebody here to do it with
my name on it you know that but I
actually get involved in this crap now
I'm down in there fighting with you on
Twitter calling you names back and all
that stuff and retweeting your stupidity
so if somebody can pick on you James
will still pull the mean tweets so I'll
still get to hear some of them when we
do Dave reads mean tweets but I might
just not read them to start off my day
or in the middle of my day I'm going to
Amy Grant's Christmas tonight I'm gonna
hear tender Tennessee Christmas with
Vince Gill sitting on the stage I got
third row seats one of my two of my
favorite people on the planet Merry
Christmas I don't need this junk in my
brain I mean Amy and Vince are nice
people they're gonna do a great
performance tonight why do I need to put
up with you oh my gosh I'm not talking
about you two in the booth you guys are
all right most the time hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]